well joining me is oceanographer Dr
David Gallo a close personal friend of
one of the men on board Paul Henry
nagioli and by Fred Hagan who's taken
the trip to visit the Titanic wreckage
twice including with Paul Omri and sub
owner Stockton rush and by submersible
expert William Conan who says he warned
Stockton rushed at the Titan sub could
be catastrophically unsuitable well
welcome to all of you let me start with
you uh Dr Gallo if I may we've talked
before when I was at CNN about uh
different kinds of situations like this
but it seems a particular crisis where
you have this tiny submersible that's
gone down to this historic site of the
Titanic and we don't know what's
happened
today there was this glimmer of hope
about whether a sound that was
resonating every 30 30 minutes maybe an
SOS signal let me start with that what
did you make of that should we read too
much into it what else could that noise
be
yeah thanks Pierce uh well yesterday uh
was a gloomy day for me because I saw
the end coming the end was near and uh I
had been paying attention to this notion
that there was an explosion heard by
seismic uh device about the same time
the sub was last heard from but then
last night we had this uh news about
these this rapping sound banging sounds
and at first I thought well here's
another rumor let me see who the source
is and it's a really credible source and
it happened multiple times and reported
by multiple different uh platforms
aircrafts so it's really boosted my uh
Braille quite a bit and I'm hoping and
praying that we have a happy ending to
this
um this uh wonderful character Paul and
Marie who's done I think 30 trips down
to a Titanic he's amassed a huge
collection of stuff that he's found
there including chandeliers and so on so
it's obviously something he's incredibly
experienced at doing
um we're seeing a picture of the two of
you together now in fact tell me about
uh Paul Omri and tell me also
someone of his experience on board is
that exactly who you need when you get a
crisis like this if they are indeed
still alive
absolutely let me clarify something when
you mentioned he amassed this collection
not personally at the time he was
working for RMS Titanic Inc and and
those are now in an artifact exhibit so
he doesn't have them personally
um yeah he's uh incredibly wise uh
battle hardened and calm as you can
imagine and pleasant as much on the deck
of a rolling ship in a hurricane as he
is sitting in a Parisian Cafe
he is the kind of guy that can Cooley
and calmly think his way through big
problems and uh just amazing he was the
person that really put everything
together for us to find Air France 447
which many thought was uh will would
never be found so uh what's sad is that
normally he'd be on this side of the
camera with me commenting on a situation
like this but now he's on the other side
of the camera so it's a bit different
for me very different for him let me
bring in uh Fred Hagin you've been
passenger on board the Titan in uh twice
in fact with Paul Omri so you know him
better than than most you also know this
vessel extremely well what are your
thoughts right now do you believe
there's hope or are we really at the end
game do you fear
as as long as there is hope we have to
make every effort to rescue them and I
have to tell you pierce thank you so
much for your eloquent introduction it's
articulated exactly what I've been
telling people that it it this human
beings are differentiated by from
Animals by that Divine spark that wants
us to achieve wants us to go further and
deeper and faster and that's what
distinguishes those gentlemen and I'm
really tired of the negativity people
trying to tear Stockton here's a man
who's who's like trying to democratize
the depths he's trying to come up with a
new technology he's pushing the envelope
and he's using the wealth of businessmen
to fund what should have been funded by
the U.S government and by governments to
research the depths of the ocean because
the depths of the ocean are fundamental
to our future that's where we're going
to find the elements the power of the
green economy and I've seen the same
remarks you're talking about even on my
social media feed people talking about
how can we spend this money to rescue
you these billionaire businessmen well
I'm going to tell you why we do that we
would do it even if they were homeless
children sitting in a cave because the
world arises to that challenge and the
poor we will have with us only Jesus
said that and that we can't go to a
better Source than that and I would also
say that this is an opportunity for the
government to pay tribute to the private
Enterprise that is driving the
technology that will be required to
explore Inner Space much as private
technology is exploring outer space so
kudos to Stockton for taking that risk
for moving forward and you know it's
like the Wright brothers when they took
that first flight and they released from
the bonds of Earth they had no backup
they had no safety plan if they'd have
crashed and gotten killed they still
would have been the first to fly he's
the first person who's trying to
democratize the depths and my hats off
to them let me ask you uh from you've
been on time so what are the conditions
likely to be like if they're still alive
and this sound this banging sound is
indeed them expressing an SOS a call for
help what would those conditions be like
inside there right now if they are right
down near the Titanic
well it's horrifying for me to think of
when I last year when I was down with ph
it you know the titanium nose it it
seeps in the the icy cold because the
water down there is at a freezing level
and it condenses and there I'm there
would be sitting on the mats in the back
of the submersible but it's a very small
space so the five of them must be laying
side by side and you know if pH is
sending these messages on a regular
basis he's doing so because and he's
doing it every 30 minutes to establish
that this is a man-made pattern and he's
doing it in because it's also giving
those five people something to occupy
their thoughts and the rest of the time
he would be having all of them sleeping
because they would consume the least
amount of oxygen so they're resting
they're sleeping and then they're every
hour they're they're getting up and
they're knocking on the shell of that
submersible that's what I hope is
happening and that's what PH would
and in terms of the amount of oxygen
they have we're told that by about 10
o'clock tomorrow morning UK time the
amount of oxygen Runs Out is that your
understanding
that is my understanding and it would be
heartbreaking to consider that a man is
warm and wonderful and dynamic his pH
could be lost to the world you know I
will personally feel impoverished and
and I got to tell you if you could if I
could make a personal comment I've said
this before you know I feel convicted
because last year pH when we got down to
the Titanic he actually sat in that
titanium nose it's freezing cold it's
full of condensation and he had slippers
on which everyone works at me I took
these soft shoot Uggs with soft sold
Uggs with sheepskin lining I meant to
buy him a pair before he went and I keep
thinking of them down there in this
cramped claustrophobic quarters with his
feet Frozen and I just you know I can't
forgive myself for the simple Act of not
sending him the boots that I intended
that I know that sounds absolutely no it
doesn't actually it sounds very it
sounds very human and very caring and
exactly how I would feel in that
situation and it's it's the whole thing
is heartbreaking it's situation these
are people who who love what they do and
and are part of history when they go
down and find stuff and and bring it
back up to the world to see but there is
a another side to this yes if I could
interject it just one thing I'd like to
say because you have referenced the
people that are talking about how
outrageous it is for us to spend this
time and money I want to remind those
people that 93 of the taxes paid in this
country are paid by businesses through
tax and remittances and we are now
returning that favor by seeking them out
and we would do that even if they were
impoverished but we do that because in
the Western World we put no price on
human life
listen I find that that politics of Envy
stuff just ridiculous and situation like
this but let me bring in William because
William Conan you actually in 2018 you
all want a 40 submersible experts you
wrote a letter to the Ocean Gate CEO
Stockton Rush warning that the
experimental Titan sub did not meet
industry standards and I understand that
you you stand by every word of that
letter today obviously you don't want to
be Vindicated as such but is this what
you feared May one day happen
yeah Paris was a uh it is a difficult
situation we have of here it's uh right
now what's uh going out in the field uh
you know we the the ocean has the
ability to Humble us uh puny humans out
here
uh it is very unforgiving and
from the perspective of the industry
that makes these vehicles
um we are humbled by the complexity of
what it takes to go down there
what we have learned over 50 years is
Humanity has learned how to safely
explore the bottom there are submarines
that go down uh 6 000 meters and more uh
every week I mean we have been doing
that for decades
we have found out how to do this safely
it takes time it is expensive
going deep is difficult and so as an
industry we have we have a North star
that we follow you might say look it's
it's it's parametric you're just
following old routines but it is working
it has allowed us to operate for 50
years without a single event
and that is to uh follow a a framework
of certification that we have built up
it's an international framework we know
it works
and that has stood Us by this is
possible and this is safe am I
understand
my understanding is that the Titan sub
was only certified to reach depths of up
to 1300 meters underwater but of course
the Titanic is nearly 4 000 meters which
is considerably further so do you do you
believe if you're being honest that it
was irresponsible to try and go this far
down with the Titan
uh it is not possible to say what the uh
what the actual parameters are appears
and and that's part of the the the the
the issue of not going through a
certification and I just want to add to
that uh the process certification sounds
like red tape but what it really is is
teamwork uh and it involves
International organizations that have
rules and regulations and inspectors and
Engineers that scrub the design that
verify how it's built that witness the
testing and what that does is it does
give a whole team of seasoned engineers
and professionals that add
to ensure nothing is missed that
everything is in order because when
you're out there under these conditions
father Neptune here does not give a lot
of seconds your concerns in that letter
in 2018 they were that the Titan did not
meet the requirements to do this kind of
voyage right
the so the origin I wrote the letter uh
I talked to Stockton about it and it did
came about because we do organize the
only conference on submersibles we
invite experts from around the world
once a year and in 2018 at the end of
the conference a number of people said
you know this is very very risky 4 000
meters for five people uh doing it
experimental without following uh our
accepted rules of of of of design and
safety is so risky what should we do uh
remaining silent didn't seem an option
we are all a bunch of nerds and
engineers in some way we have a very
strong feeling and passion for uh as
engineers in general duty of care
and there are certain things that uh
we must take care of because it is not
reasonable for
normal citizens
we're running out of time but William
just do you believe that there is any
hope that they will survive this
yes yes there is uh I agree we have to
make all the efforts as long as we are
it is it is an issue the fact that we
have completely lost communication early
on and we don't know where it is and
right now uh searching a small
submersible like that in a White Field
is so difficult but if we can find them
we can hook up to them and bring them to
surface let's leave it there on that
positive note and hope that that is
positivity which is met and borne out by
events in the next uh in the next few
hours well no I mean sadly by tomorrow
morning uh the oxygen runs out so
there's a horrible ticking clock on this
and we can only hope and pray that they
do come forward and there is a miracle
thank you both all three of you very
much indeed for joining I appreciate it